un nuevo revés para el presidente
panameño laurentino cortizo los
sindicatos y gremios que impulsan una
ola de protestas desde hace casi dos
semanas no acudieron al diálogo
convocado por el gobierno alegando una
falta de consensos previos los cierres a
lo largo de la carretera interamericana
que conecta a panamá con el resto de
centroamérica continúan al igual que las
manifestaciones en todo el país en
protesta por el aumento de los precios
de los combustibles alimentos y
medicinas iniciemos y hacer un llamado
al presidente de la republica que
atiende a nuestra petición a no atender
esta petición nosotros ya entonces hemos
les hemos al nivel nacional del
territorio indígena de panamá la crisis
fue provocada por distintos factores el
precio del combustible prácticamente se
ha duplicado desde enero y el costo de
los productos de primera necesidad se ha
disparado en un intento de calmar los
ánimos el presidente anunció la
congelación de los precios del gas y de
varios productos de primera necesidad
pero los manifestantes consideran que no
es suficiente y demasiado tarde como él
pretende que con 10 alimentos de la
canasta básica que anoto vamos a poder
subsistir es imposible ni siquiera está
la carne de res el pollo o el arroz que
es lo más básico que debemos comer todos
los días los panameños están a la espera
de la redacción de una nueva carta magna
una promesa incumplida de los últimos
tres gobiernos el mandatario ha culpado
a la pandemia y a la guerra en ucrania
del alza de precios